um uh did you skip the SAS bit in this I
did yeah
that's what that's what people want to
hear back back back
when I was 18. uh We've long last got
the point where brexit is now looking
like it's working as it broadly should
do you think that this conservative
party values Freedom no no not not
enough well I've already characterized
but the the single most important things
relate to Freedom right
um an assumption the state doesn't know
best I don't want Whitehall managing my
identity I own my identity if I'm going
to have an identity an identifier I want
it under my control you may remember
early on uh some of us said this looks
like a virus that's come from
laboratory and God did you get Hillary
for saying that online not just Hillary
you get banned off places like indeedy a
Nobel Prize is that was the first point
by the way in this whole process where I
said well I saw French Nobel Prize
winner effectively banned from talking
about his expert subjects you know and I
thought you know this is wrong
foreign
ometry
from the unheard offices in central
London I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is one of the few MPS in
this country left who actually cares
about civil liberties David Davis
welcome to trigonometry thank you it's
great to have you on the show we don't
normally talk to politicians because
it's hard to get a straight answer out
of you guys but I get the sense that a
you've kind of you've been there you've
done it you've you've spoken up quite a
lot about the things that you care about
and also unlike many MPS you actually
had a life before politics and an
interesting one so I thought it would be
a great place to start actually tell us
about your life and and how you are
where you are okay
um a quick a quick fire summary uh born
son of a single mum 1948 when it was
unfashionable
yeah
controversial right off the bat
excellent
um brought up by my grandparents whilst
I mean because in those days you know
you just didn't raise your own child so
she went off to to work to do the job
they raised me in a in a prefab you know
what that is no asbestos box in in the
second world war when a sticker bombs
went down the street uh that they they
would bulldoze the street and put little
asbestos boxes ready-made houses made in
a factory prefab
um uh they're quite famous and uh so I
grew up in one of those everybody thinks
it's terrible you know awful sounds like
it sounds like a Monty Python sketch
straight off actually it was fantastic
because they're well designed uh had a
nice Central Heating and so on and
um uh albeit rather cramped and you know
and uh and so I lived just inside the
walls of York other kids had bouncy
castles I had a real one
so that was that was early life but then
then my mother got married uh my
stepfather
working class shop steward actually and
we lived in a slum in South London just
south of the River from here
um literally two up two down no
electricity gas uh
um no indoor Lou no bathroom but Tim Tim
and all that sort of stuff
um uh nothing unusual I mean that
frankly it sounds terrible but actually
was not that unusual post-war
um then uh past 11 plus most important
probably most important event in my life
with a past 11 plus went to grab school
right
um uh did well at grammar school
um uh enjoyed Sports broke my nose lots
of times
um playing rugby uh ended up I'll
foreshortened this I left home in a
rather violent
disagree with my stepfather
um ended up going to Warwick University
I've studied science molecular sciences
and computer science very pretty much
the first computer science degree in the
country while I was there
Margaret Thatcher was the education
secretary and I became the national
leader of the conservative students sort
of a thing called Federation
constitutions about 15 000 from
organization meant I get to sit I get to
see her about 10 times a year get to see
Ted Heath the Prime Minister about four
times a year uh in a funny way a rather
privileged access uh
um then we then we lost power in the 70s
uh item went out I then went to business
school London Business School uh took an
MBA became businessman
um I spent my time working with Tate and
Lyle as their troubleshooter principally
uh putting right
companies losing money gone wrong
um and did that
um until uh the early 80s then became an
MP in 1987.
um uh did you skip the SAS bit in this I
did yeah
that's what that's what the people want
to hear back back
when I was 18. uh now people don't
understand this
um because they all think it's terribly
glamorous it's not
um I needed to earn money I basically
I'd left home right I was supporting
myself I had to get a job I'd earn money
to get University because in those days
were grants and my parents weren't going
to support my grant they weren't even
going to fill in the form so I couldn't
get a grant so the penworth university
so one way of doing it
um uh was to join the reserve SAS
um which was
um arduous
the pass rate in the selection was eight
percent you know mostly people this is
like the Navy Seals for American
audience right harder harder yeah harder
there's a lot of angry Americans and
that's fine that's fine well if you just
take it in objective pass rate terms
um uh the the pass rate uh for for the
SS is is is a little lower
um uh and of course the SAS in the first
instance was probably the first of the
modern Special Forces started in the
second world war David Sterling and all
that I mean I used to learn
um he was still alive when I was around
um and we are very
um
the reserver say yes not the regulars
had uh rather dramatic one level Monday
and one level dramatic job our primary
role in Warfare would in the event of a
conflict in Europe was to jump in Behind
Enemy Lines up to 300 kilometers Behind
Enemy Lines uh find the targets maybe
create the targets by causing the odd
traffic jam
um uh tank traffic jam as well as you
actually actually as as you've seen him
in the last year in truth our job was to
sort of create that find it Target it
by morse code send in the the the
locations uh and call in missile strikes
probably nuclear missile strikes in a in
a conventional war in Europe
um so survival expectation wasn't very
hard uh in fact when I was when I was
doing parachute
School Abington in in um just not just
north of Oxford uh RAF happened that
used to used to be there
um we'd had this incredibly dramatic
um
screw up on the jump whereby my
parachute Tangled
with somebody else if somebody else flew
his shoot over mine uh dropped and
because of the low pressure Zone above
shoot that's super dangerous his feet
came through I looked up so his feet it
was 105 foot above the ground thought
this shoot can't carry two so I pulled
down the one side of my shoot to get to
get him off uh instead of sliding off he
slid through the Chute so the two shoots
just collapse into one another
and he was hanging about as far away as
you are screaming mother mother not
again I won't tell you what I said back
and we just had fell towards the ground
and I was lucky
I walked away from it
um he broke he shortened his leg broke
all his leg bones and broke his back and
within a within a body cast for six
months anyway the point about the story
is not that as we came back into the
into the barracks on the little black
and white tube television that they used
to have in those days about this big you
know deep
um there was a picture of Soviet t-62s
invading Prague August 1968 I thought I
thought expletive deleted I'm only going
to live three months
so that was that was the backdrop there
and we and we did lots of other things
but those I can't talk about but that
bit's public domain so yeah right so
before you jump in David you mentioned a
whole bunch of things that I want to dig
into first but here you are you're
growing up sung of a single mother yeah
you know probably I mean you say you
know it was pretty common but you're not
you're not living in the lap of luxury
no and you you become conservative how
did that happen well it wasn't initially
because my grandfather was a communist
in fact my grandfather been in prison
uh on a couple of occasions
um for supposedly leading a riot
actually leading a demonstration in
those days they didn't distinguish much
um that's how Liberty the organization
came performed naturally it was a
National Council civil liberties because
of the treatment of demonstrators by the
police
and so I grew up in a Marxist background
and I've thought to myself as very
left-wing
um until I went to University
and a series of different things came
together
uh you know for example when we had a
mock election at my school I stood as a
communist candidate you know got one
vote and it wasn't mine
but just take power anyway David yeah
that's right just take it take it by
other methods but the uh anyway the uh
so very left to Center
um I was
um left to center Liberal not left to
Center Marxist really so for example I
was in favor of homosexual law reforms
since I've always said when people say
to me who was the greatest Home
Secretary of your lifetime I say Roy
Jenkins
which puts surprises conservatives
because you know he introduced
censorship reform uh abolish the death
penalty uh homosexual law reform all
those things came in under under that
government and I was entirely on site
with it and I still am um the um uh I
have slightly nuanced views on death
penalty but they're not important ones
um the uh and but then I went I went out
to work to earn a living uh was in the
Army and so I had to look quite hard at
what the Soviet threat really was in a
way that other people didn't I mean we
had all the classified briefings and
looking at what their what their War
plans were and so on
um and I went to University during 1968
which was
um well it's an extraordinarily pivotal
year in all sorts of ways social ways
modern ways to the modern society and
all of that led me quite quickly within
a course about 12 months to come to a a
view which is really the most important
thing
uh in a in a good Society in a civilized
society are individual freedoms
uh rights under the law
um robust Democratic systems by which I
mean ones that don't collapse and I'm
going to annoy your American audience
again in the way that the American one
has sort of got bent out of shape by by
Obama Trump Biden and so on
um uh all those things became very
important to me and it seemed to me the
best institutional representation of
that was the conservative party right
didn't mean I agree with everything they
did or believed in in fact I actually
signed up my entire student
um a federation set of students to
Amnesty International which of course
oh Ben
um because you know at the same time as
believing in a capitalist economy which
is the best way to deliver things I've
talked about and an economy where the
rule of law is predominant again the
best way I also believed in things like
not torturing people not imprisoning
people without things that actually last
into my life really
um so that's really where it came from
it was it was the first time frankly I
thought properly about it rather than
just inherited views you see because my
grandfather's a communist and my
stepfather was an ex-communist labor
voter we had Rao after row after I was a
shop steward and so we'd argue all the
time about uh Trade Union uh although
I'm very pro-union uh we are all the
time so so up until up until as where I
acquired my Independence I didn't really
exercise my brain once I did it was a
very quick decision and what is within a
year and what does it mean to you to be
a conservative
well it means the single well I've
already characterized but the the single
most important things relate to Freedom
right
um uh an assumption the state doesn't
know best
all right uh and this this has
re-surfaced in the last decade or two or
post all the counter-terrorism stuff and
now the the woke stuff where somehow
there's a view that that the collective
approach to things is more important
than the individual and that's almost
invariably wrong you know and and and
the trouble is it's also written into
the mindsets of even some of our more
talented uh conservative politicians I
mean you you let me give you an example
again I'll annoy somebody else I don't
know a lot excellent the views are going
to be through them I will go clever man
I was his referee and so on and all that
but he you know he talks about
um Florence when we're talking about
what Britain's gonna be like post brexit
it talks about Florence and how and how
he attributes to the medicis all the
successes of Florence and bugger all to
do with the medicis it was all to do was
a chaos of Florence Florence is a City
full of Alchemists and people and weird
weird religious sects and so on
um and because it allowed the freedom of
all that chaos uh and bad ideas out of a
thousand bad ideas half a dozen really
good ones and a half a dozen Geniuses
you know the michelangelos and so on
emerged yeah
um and I think I I think human nature is
such and a well-designed institutions as
such that if you allow a lot more
freedom then you're quite comfortable
with you get a really good outcome
because eventually the best the best
emerges it's a sort of intrinsic
meritocracy of chaotic societies how's
that for you
I completely agree with you David and I
think that freedom is one of the things
that I value most highly yeah
do you think that this conservative
party values Freedom no no not not
enough
um uh
one one of the one of the difficulties
with freedom when when States
particularly in a sort of democratic
State like ours
um address a new threat I'll use the
word mildly
invariably that impinges on freedom all
right uh and all the and all the the the
sort of
uh the Disciples of Freedom the
intellectual Disciples of Freedom
privacy and things like that right so
let me give an example
um early during the player years
um Blair was absolutely obsessed with
the idea of identity cards he's just
come up with it again last week you
noticed uh him and him and Hague
um
um and at the time because this was
being presented as a way of protecting
people you know we can find terrorists
more easily out I don't know you think
they're right terrorists down as their
occupation
um but they they had this idea right and
and 80 of the public agreed with it
what actually changed the Public's mind
was that the State lost two CDs tax
records of 26 million people all the
home addresses the bank accounts as they
just disappeared you know the two CDs
and within a month it was 70 against
rather than 80 in favor because people
saw the the the the the dangers of of
centralized data on people and this this
resurrects every time
I uh White tour just down the road from
here uh believes in something called
identity management I don't want
Whitehall managing my identity I own my
identity if I'm going to have an
identity an identifier I want it under
my control I want it my solicitor or my
lawyer or my bank or whatever I don't
want the state control of my identity
but they think it's a great they think
it's the answer to everything because
when you give them the data they mess it
up anyway they get it wrong they lose it
they to the wrong people but
um but it's you know it's a I think
identity car is quite a good
demonstrator what looks like a very
sensible you know plausible managerial
idea actually when you do it
State makes a real and holy mess of it
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean executed for not
being real men which is correct well for
those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and will have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com it's time to throw
out all your old hygiene habits and
upgrade your life
David can you explain something to me I
I'm not from this country I was born in
the Soviet Union and when I came here in
in the mid 90s I was like oh this is a
country that believes in Freedom yeah
right that's what I thought yeah and I
cannot tell you how shocked I was in the
last few years particularly with code
now I remember the ID card debate I
remember opposing it at the time didn't
remember 80 of people supported it which
is kind of relevant to my question
because look in a crisis when there's
danger and fear of course the government
is going to use that as an opportunity
to seize more power to accumulate more
data to do all that that's
understandable we've seen it all around
the world
but the polling from people that we saw
you know 20 of people want nightclubs
closed down irrespective okay you know
all of this stuff I was going what what
the hell is going on here right now
what I'm hearing out of you is people
perhaps are less well-informed people
are terrified and they were terrified by
the government by the media and so on
but I mean what happened during covert
well no I mean two things
to get straight first I mean number one
is most of the time most people don't
think about politics
right I mean uh it was it was true
because they're saying yeah they
delegate it to people like me right and
um and it's my job to have these fights
on their behalf and they don't think
about it very much so
um uh so so that that's the first thing
to understand
um second thing is when they do first
think about it not the eventual
conclusion but what do you do first
thing about it the first template the
first test quite properly is how will it
affect me or my family or whatever and
if I'm frightened at my granny or my mum
uh or me will catch covid you know and
they're in a risk category then I'll
forget everything else I said yeah right
okay do what's necessary lock him up
whatever
and that's that's perfectly natural yeah
that's that is you know as human beings
we're built to defend our families you
know
hundreds of thousands of years of of of
uh evolution of of programmers that way
but then people think they start to
think about it in carefully and then
they balance things up you know and
there's that sequence first not paying
any attention then the first attention
what's my own there's a sort of
hierarchy of needs type argument and
then as a more thoughtful thing and when
you saw this I mean I in 2008 I had a
by-election because because
um because we lost the vote in the
Commons over 42 days detention without
charge and because I didn't believe that
that when it came down to it when the
when the government brought it back as
they would just before an election that
David Cameron would resist it I didn't
want to be that Home Secretary was going
to impose that
um uh so I forced to buy election now
again at the time 70 of people thought
for you to today's detention without
charge was for terrorism suspects was a
good idea in indeed some people said
what's wrong with 42 years you know but
they heard the terrorism they didn't
hear the suspects right and it was in
the aftermath of the seven seven
bombings and all that so you can
understand people you know they imagine
this terrible event uh uh we should do
everything possible because later on
they start thinking through the details
who are the people who actually get held
for six weeks what it is uh without
charge which people against whom you
have no evidence
it's people who live in the same house
as the person who did it not the person
themselves people who themselves get
they get charged in five or six days so
what happened over the course of I don't
know about five weeks of a local
localized uh by-election
uh was that people started to think
about it and again it went that one went
from 70 30 one way to 70 30 the other
way over the course because I made
people think terrorist suspect right so
again it's just that people they
rationed their time they ration their
thought process they ration the effort
the interest they they waste on things
you know they want to raise their
children they want to do their job they
want to save for their pension whatever
they don't want to spend their time
thinking about things that the state
should do properly first time but David
is that what happened during covert
because I don't remember it like that it
hasn't no it hasn't it seemed to me that
the level of authoritarianism both in
the government and the public increased
it has gone and it hasn't yet reversed
you see no and I and and I think that
process is a slower process of going on
at the moment
um and part of the problem is the sort
of public censorship that's going on you
know it was very difficult to get a
proper hearing I mean in the
conservative party for example that I
wasn't a member of it but the thing
called the coronavirus research group I
think it was I mean one it's it's
chairman is now a Cabinet member
um so you know there is at least some
but I think what's going to happen
is slowly over time the weaknesses in
the state argument
will become apparent you're seeing it
today you're seeing it with the while as
we sit here the front phase of Daily
Telegraph is is a story taken from Matt
Hancock's what's that exchanges uh
suggesting that he was wasn't actually
going from science at all he was going
from other whatever other convenient
politically convenient reasons he he had
for making those decisions we'll see the
uh the outcome of that but what's
happening Tom we saw somewhere else we
saw
um you may remember early on uh some of
us said this looks like a virus that's
come from
a laboratory and God did you get
pilloried for saying that online and not
just Hillary you get banned off places
like that indeedy a Nobel Prize is that
was the first point by the way in this
whole process where I said well I saw a
French Nobel Prize winner effectively
banned from talking about his expert
subjects you know and I thought you know
this is wrong we need to deal with this
information at the source test
well you're all coming you had to do
with it misinformation
yes exactly but the um so so the uh
that's beginning to break up that's
beginning to come apart and
um and one of the one of the things I am
going to be focusing on in that here or
two is trying to make sure that the
inquiry is
um uh is actually looks at all the facts
and takes them all on board and why is
that important why does that matter well
it matters because there is a unique
characteristic to this and the unique
characteristic which I've never seen
before in my lifetime anyway is that uh
every single ruling establishment in the
world possibly accepting Sweden made the
same mistake
and ruling establishments are very bad
at omitting mistakes and when they're
defending each other you know you've got
the World Health Organization you've got
you've got uh America the American
government the British government all of
these all all the European governments
they all essentially made the same
mistakes and so it's gonna be quite hard
to tease it apart but I think it's going
to be one of the big jobs over the next
couple of years two or three years to to
get it right because but partly protect
freedom from unnecessary incursions but
also partly to make sure next time we
have a pandemic we respond in a way
which actually deals with it
rather than sort of behaves in a sort of
politically defensive way which is
really what we're looking at the
political defensiveness by every
establishment in the world
um so you know it's at the last time
something like this happened probably
was when the Catholic church was the
dominant force and that's what I know
the 10th Century onwards sort of thing
um you know when you only have one one
allowed mindset
um and uh
so you know it's it's it's going to be
um a
the next five years not the next year
the next five years like it's going to
be a long long battle to get the facts
straight
and are you going to be covering
misappropriation of funds as well when
it comes to PPE and
oh yeah I mean look I I used to be
we skin possible sorts of things but I
used to be the Public Accounts committee
chairman
um and uh I take the view that
proper operation of the state
uh in terms of looking after people's
money is one of the first
responsibilities you know it's the first
duty of the state not to not to take
your money and waste it or throw it away
or Worse worst of all hand it over in a
corrupt process to to your favorite
supporters whatever it might be and if
that's what's happened I'm not going to
prejudge these things but if that's
what's happened then the judicial system
should come down on it like a ton of
bricks
absolutely David a real criticism that
people have at the conservative party
and I think is a very valid one is that
the conservative party isn't
conservative it no longer represents
conservative people it got elected
to implement brexit which they've done
but you look at what the some of the
policies that they've brought in and I'm
not a conservative but I'm looking at
that going that is almost more Center
left or left than it is conservative
well the first thing to say about the
conservative party is it's it's pretty
bloody difficult to Define what
conservative means right if you if you
if you looked at my philosophy and this
hasn't changed since I had to Parliament
uh you can probably more accurately
describe me as a gladstoneian liberal
you know uh low taxes free trade uh free
movement rule of law all these we've
talked already
um and the conservative party is a um an
alliance it's it's not a single entity
you know it's always had a range of a
array a spectrum okay let me put it in a
more specific way yeah people if I'm a
red wall voter I don't think I voted to
have for example this is just one
example picked out at random I don't
think I voted to have 40 000 people come
into this country illegally in small
boats I don't think I voted and look I
I'm allowed to say this as an immigrant
myself I don't think I've when when I
when you told me tens of thousands I
don't think I voted for hundreds of
thousands right so irrespective of
whether that's a conservative policy I
know I think Francis point is it's not a
governance delivering on his commitments
not yet no it isn't I mean the I mean
part of the problem I mean we're talking
at a difficult time in terms of
answering this question because you've
had obviously brexit you've had more
importantly in many ways covid you've
got Ukraine you've got the fracturing of
the world trading system which is in
many ways may be the most important yes
um all these really really important
structures have been
buggered up am I like to say that one
yeah we swear all the time say whatever
you want and and and of course we've had
what three changes a leader really I
mean since since Cameron I mean uh
through all this and so uh in terms of
political distraction it's been quite
the normal Focus you know that as I say
the low taxes control of our borders uh
all all those standard Tory actually
standard good management things really
um I've I've slept no doubt about it
that's a very gentle word to use to
describe what's happened
we've got the corporation taxes every
tax that I can see is going up right no
control of our borders whatsoever like I
I think it's I think look this isn't an
attempt to attack you or the
conservative party I mean as Francis
says neither of us is conservative but
yeah it's not good like it's not and
it's not delivering for the people who
voted for the conservative party well
one of one of the one of the
difficulties is that um and this this is
this applies to all parties not just
because third parties
there's a tendency in this day and age
uh and it's and it really mostly started
not uniquely but mostly started under
Blair and it's got worse ever since is
there's a tendency to replace actual
answers with populist answers so let me
give you an example
on migration okay
um I have opposed the Rwanda policy
um partly because I think it's sort of
uncivilized but also participating at
work right yeah but if you go out if
you've been on the street and you
stopped 100 people 80 would think is a
great idea right which is why in my view
it's it's the policy and we've seen it
says Blair Blair used to talk
in in big terms you know about cracking
down migration on you know and all the
various anti-crime things crime got
worse under Blair but but yeah you know
it had all sorts of
um uh the things he was talking about
and on terrorism course as well and the
trouble is that people hear the policy
if it sounds tough great that's
wonderful truth is what we need to do on
something like
um the the votes across a channel is
some of it's down to uh some really
simple sensible things I wrote to the
Prime Minister before Christmas you
wouldn't necessarily remember with
initially 50 other MPS on the letter but
turned out to be 100 after I've got a
bit coverage
um saying look just Define Albania as a
safe country because it is Albania's had
fewer references to the European Court
the last 10 years than we I should all
be fleeing to Albany exactly I have a
better I have a better case to go to
Toronto than they do yeah yeah right
um and uh let's first do that it doesn't
solve the problem but but golly it
knocks about 15 000 or 12 000 people out
of it straight away you know for third
of the uh of the overall total um let's
do that get that under control
um I've also said not in the letter but
I've said to the the various people
involved in this you know you've got to
improve the the cross-child surveillance
you know a British company provides
frontex which is the European
um uh border agency with the
surveillance for the uh for the
Mediterranean light aircraft to an
engine light aircraft a da62 for your
for your techie viewers uh complete the
with synthetic aperture radar with
infrared with long range cameras with
um devices that detect
um uh mobile phones and you know the
combination of all of them they can spot
people arriving at the beach in Libya so
I think it's popular arriving at the
beach in Libya from International
airspace they can spot people arriving
at the beach in France from British
airspace the French tellers they can't
do it because of privacy concerns well
I'm a privacy Enthusiast and I don't see
that but never mind that's their view
but we could do that and we could we
should have been telling them every time
somebody they're there every single one
so why don't we
I think it's a I think it's a comp I
think it's a government competence thing
I think the home office throughout
really since remember my reference to um
Roy Jenkins really since those days I
don't think the home office has been
functional and they've been desperate
attempts to make it work prisons have
been taken out justice has been taken
out and they still quite haven't got the
the department probably functional I
think there is a there is a serious
problem of competence in Whitehall
generally decline of competence over the
last 20 30 years
um but I can see why you're not
administering it
I had this conversation once I probably
shouldn't tell you with whom but let's
say somebody who was at the top of the
White Hall regime
uh and I said you served in the um the
Lawson treasury you know tell me uh is
today's white wall is competent as it
was in Thatcher's time
and this and he thought for a second he
said no I said why not he said well in a
treasury case you know you've got the
the very clever youngsters who used to
go to to become treasury policy
principals you know uh are now making a
million a year in a city you know post
Big Bang
um post uh Blair Blair Blair gave a lot
of extra power to special advisors the
the Alistair Campbell's of the world and
so on which of course he took that power
away from the policy advisors in the
foreign office and and in the cabinet
officer so so what happened was that uh
we uh we basically aren't doing as good
a job we also rotate people too often
and lots and lots of tiny techy things
like like Blair made it the case used to
be in order to become perm secretary you
had to serve in The Minister's private
office now similar Minister's private
office is a nightmare you know you're
working seven days a week you know for
long hours a minute I can call you up at
midnight and and all that and I used to
just come on the news what's going on
sort of thing you know
um and but but you know if you want to
get to top that's what you did well you
know think changes rules lots and lots
of changes rules like that and other
ones as well has has reduced the
effectiveness of Whitehall I think and
and we over covered you know you you
also saw another decline in the effect
as you saw it with um the uh the case
officers the rate of the case officers
cleared or dealt with Asylum cases down
to 1.4 a week well that's sort of
Madness you know it should be about five
times that a day you know it should be
four or five a day
um and uh and those sorts of things you
know you've got a real you've got real
serious competence issues I think given
the size of the problems and that so I'm
sorry it's a long-winded answered your
question why are we not doing the
surveillance and I think that's part of
the reason
um we also got we've also got young imp
you've got young politicians too you
know before I came into the house I've
been working in business the main board
director of a fancy 100 company before I
became an MP
um uh and that's not that common anymore
so there's some it's true for some but
most people
most is probably putting it too strongly
but a very large proportion of MPS
coming in now are expats they've done
nothing but working white wall and so on
and actually you know if you're
representing people you want to have
done something in the outside world not
just something in government you know I
think it I think it's really really
important that and that's that's decline
there's no individual's fault it's a
it's a social Trend that's happened
David you spoke in an interview about
how there's only been two
transformational prime ministers one of
which was Margaret Thatcher and I look
at the current political cohort that we
have and it seems that they lack one
fundamental quality necessary to be a a
good leader and that is the willingness
to be unpopular and to be hated and I
look at all our leaders and they don't
seem to want to be disliked they don't
seem to want to annoy people which if
you want to transform things if you want
to make things better you've got to make
unpleasant and difficult and unpopular
decisions well let's be clear about one
thing Margaret didn't want that
she had to get used to it yeah all right
okay but she was prepared but she was
prepared the lady's not for turning but
when I first knew her yes you know she
had she was Margaret Thatcher milk
snatcher yeah your two both of you too
young to remember the Scandal but she uh
Scandal she she had canceled free school
milk for certain categories of
youngsters and
um and she got used to it but the thing
you have to understand is that Margaret
was very
calculating
it's probably the right word about that
um
she when she took on a big problem let's
say she took on the issue of over Mighty
unions or took on the issue of the uh of
the miners strike or whatever right she
would take this big strategic game she'd
set out the big strategic aim but then
she'd salami slice it into small pieces
and do it one piece at a time ideally
only one enemy at a time yeah not a
thousand enemies well it's in 1974 Ted
Heath lost the election because he
basically made an enemy about 300
different groups over industrial
relations and then got thrown out by by
the unions really
um she would cut it into little bits
um so give you an example uh with the
miner strike um number one when Derek
Ezra tried to precipitate it before she
was ready she sacked him you know she
didn't sack anybody else she sacked the
head of the coldboard
um during it she she won that conflict
um albeit great social cost but
um
uh during it she was scared by the
Dockers coming out on a wildcat strike
which he had not prepared for and so
ever ever thereafter until I changed her
mind she avoided having a conflict with
the Dockers you know and then I said
I've got a reform the scheme the doc
labor scheme and so we did but it took a
long time because she was very very
careful she was she was much more a
woman than a man on this I think women
are much better sometimes at dealing
objectively with risk than we are we're
sort of sometimes brought up to sort of
rush head first into risks
it's not clever in politics she
understood what needed to be done and
she did it and notably she always did
the unpopular things in the first year
or two so
it's sort of unfair to apply this to
sunac because he hasn't got
spare time to do this but generally
speaking I think
um you're right that the the people
modern politicians haven't got in the
habit of thinking through right okay
what am I going to do in year one year
two year three because by year four she
always had the results to show you see
and she always went to year four you
know and in a very calculated way
um uh you know uh this one so this
wasn't sort of you know the political
equivalent of winning a Victoria Cross
you know Margaret was about winning the
battle and all right there's some pain
to take early on but she you she
calculated it out and and I think people
very few people in in
in the House of Commons have a real
memory of Margaret all right
um so for example when Liz truss was
presenting herself as a modern marketing
nothing like it Michael would never have
done what Bliss and quasi did with that
budget you know frankly in my view a mad
budget
um because you know it lost the markets
it lost everything if you would have
should have done that calculation
properly she would have got Lawson or
how or whoever whoever was the chance of
the sit down and work out what you could
do and what would maximize uh the the
effects and so on and minimize the risks
so yeah
um she was willing to to be unpopular it
really really
um that gen that post-war generation was
much more tough-minded I think in many
ways no matter what the you know Tory or
labor or liberal for that matter
um less liberal because they weren't
really in play Victoria labor or willing
sometimes to stand up I mean Barbara
Castle he read your history books
Barbara Castle and the place of strife
trying to sort out the trade unions our
Wilson ran away from it but the at least
started down the road so that's a
journey some to something a generational
thing you know when I came into House of
Commons my two predecessors the ones the
members for Howden and Halton price were
the last two double decorated members of
the house they both had a military cross
and a distinguished service order and
that's always prayed on my mind these
are people who you know
were patriotic in the sense of hand and
putting themselves In Harm's Way for
their country but also looked after
their regiment in North Africa for two
or three years so that well I've got to
deal with a constituency issue of
somebody's planning problem or
somebody's uh can't make ends meet or
whatever you know they've got Jimmy
whose wife has left him they've got
Johnny who can't pay his debts they got
Frankie who's a an alcoholic and so on
and they they have to deal with all that
so they they from the beginning had a
far closer grasp I think of ordinary
people's concerns than subsequent
Generations have had I I was going to
say but this is a very real problem
David because if you don't understand
the concerns or the lives of ordinary
people with the best will in the world
how are you then going to enact policies
that are going to help these well I
agree I agree and but I think it's a
systemic problem now against that you've
got
um a circumstance where the caseload of
MPS is much bigger than it used to be so
the argument the the counter argument to
me will be well that brings them closer
to uh to the people but but I think I
just think that British Society has
become more stratified
uh got more layers in it now than
actually I had when I was growing up I
think I mean nobody wants to wish a war
in a country
um but the the one of the effects of the
second well actually one of the effects
of the 1930s and the 1940s together was
to make us feel more of a Nation yeah
you know didn't always help the Tories I
mean after we got wiped out in 1945 you
know
um but I think there was and indeed the
Tories had more working-class votes in
those days as well even the now
um uh but yeah it uh that sense of
nationhood was very important nationhood
Society call it what you want it's a
it's a commonality
um uh and uh you know that we've lost a
bit of that and I think I think
although we all know what everybody's
thinking because the social media these
days it's an incredibly fragmented
um Society it reflects
yeah you you look at strands of social
media
it's so
intolerant of of other viewpoints that
instead of having
um a debate
where if you sort of did a distribution
diagram of people's opinions along a
spectrum it would tend to be that shape
you know be a normal distribution
sometimes it was like a Dromedary you
know two humps you know slightly
different but there was always something
in the middle I sometimes easily I'm
talking about I don't know brexit or
covid or uh or woke issues or whatever I
sometimes feel it's just two competing
Echo Chambers and there's nowhere in the
middle in fact if you stand the middle
you get shot out by everybody that's
right yeah well that's what we do yeah
okay it's a lot of fun but David I want
to move on from the Party politics but
first I want to ask you a final question
on that is your party going to lose the
next election no not necessarily I think
um I think if you'd ask me that
um six months ago I would have said we
had a one in ten chance at best if not
zero I think it's improved to one in
five uh and
um I mean
twenty percent that's twenty percent
from ten percent so that's doubled in a
week that is the politician
s because we've got we've got a budget
coming up yeah all right uh and I think
what the budget does is very important
the issue you've been talking about
um of of borders you know I think there
are some solutions available I've talked
about the Albanian issue uh and the more
practical issue of how we deal with it
um I think there's quite a lot going on
there I've been I've been I've been
talking a lot to number 10 about those
things yeah I used to be Shadow Home
Secretary for five years I mean I used
to be a specialist in removing
homosexaries when they were laborers
um so you know you can imagine I have
views on that and I think those three
issues could move it the other way I
mean that's the thing
um so I you know I've been around in
politics long enough to see much much
worse circumstances were it than we're
in now and I think really yeah oh yeah I
mean bear in mind I was I was I was uh I
was an MP in 1997 you know when we had a
hundred and whatever it was Fortner that
was worse for the conservative party I
don't think the country was in a worse
State than than it is now you're coming
to the good State I mean the the amazing
irony there was that we delivered a
fantastic economy and we've got zero
credit for it so no no no no no there's
no doubt that the countries but all
countries yes I mean I mean
what
what I said to you before I'm a sort of
gladstoneian liberal in my in my
intrinsic Politics the
um
in my view
the greatest positive thing that's
happened in the history of the world in
the last century
happened in 1995. and what happened then
was the World Trade Organization uh and
the Gap round had a dramatic reduction
of extra uh tariff barriers around the
world and what that did was it led to
about one and a half billion people
billion 1 500 million people
uh coming out of absolute poverty so in
my view probably the greatest event in
modern times
um and if we're not careful
that trade liberalization could go into
reverse Ukraine China Taiwan the the
Chinese State capitalist Behavior Huawei
and all those other issues
um so you've got that that's huge you've
got uh other knock-on effects obviously
Ukraine
um uh the the what is in effect the
attempt to create the old so recreate
the old Soviet Union
um uh is
going to be agonizing one way or another
the outcome either either for the west
or the or for Russia
at some point uh you've you know you've
got post-brexit I think that's all of a
sudden that's a rather different color
that looks much warmer than it did
before
um you've got a United States that's
sort of indecisive and where it is in
the world at the moment I mean um I
didn't like Trump don't get me wrong I
dislike Trump intensely very bad
influence but I'm I'm not sure that
Biden's uh a great leader either
um for all sorts of reasons so so you
know of course we've got a huge number
of problems but they're not just British
problems they are a worldwide problems
well let's let's talk about one of them
which is the war in Ukraine and one of
the things that we saw during covert
particularly is uh the breakdown of
trust in what we were being told that
had been going on for some time I think
it probably really kicked off in 2015
2016 and the way that it is going now
we've got to a point now where there's a
lot of people particularly people who
are sort of anti-work or maybe lean
right who who quite understandably I
think really distrust what anyone is
telling them from the mainstream media
politicians Etc and we've got to a point
with Ukraine where I'm sort of tearing
what's left of my hair out in the sense
that there are quite a lot of people
sort of delved into all sorts of
conspiracy theories in fact we had a
debate with Peter Hitchens only a few
days ago in here talking and there are
people who think this is all NATO's
fault and and all of this I actually
disagree with you about the attempt to
recreate the Soviet Union Putin wants to
recreate the Russian Empire that's why
he hates Lenin so much because he gave
away parts of the Soviet Union of what
the Russian Empire to create so you know
but
from sw1 they look quite similar
I can imagine well the Russian Empire
was bigger I know you've got to remember
um but in any case uh we talked about
Thatcher as well
how do you think she would have handled
this for a start
very clinically you mean the Ukraine yes
episode
very clinically probably in a quite
similar way to
um
to what's been done are you the supply
of arms rather than uh direct
intervention
um
you might have been a bit more
aggressive in the first part she
wouldn't she wouldn't have she wouldn't
have allowed direct engagement but she
might have done something like I don't
know
um provide a no-fly zone for the west of
Ukraine something like that something
designed to stay out of entanglement but
to provide some sort of safe spaces she
might have done that but broadly
speaking should have done something
similar to what we're doing now she
would probably have taken a more active
International role push push around and
then then
any British current British prime
minister really able to do
um because bear in mind the structures
in her day were far more entrenched in
place I mean
I remember vertly uh sitting in the Tea
Room not in the Tea Room in the in the
in the dining room the House of Commons
and she came in sat next to me and I
said and it was at the time of the
Reykjavik talks
um and um I said what you've been doing
Margaret she said I've been
straightening out Ronnie
and we forget of course that that you
envelope was very important yeah it had
some friction from time to time over
Grenada and other things but but that
Jew Umbra was very important and there's
no real equivalent to you around today
um so but she would have been very and
she that would have been incredibly
clinical exercise and how far can we go
remember what I said before about
controlling risk you know what's a
strategic aim how strategame would have
been I'm quite sure complete expulsion
uh of Russia from Ukraine she might have
she might have uh had a different view
about Crimea because crimea's got
different histories you know but the but
the um but she broadly speak I think she
would have gone through she would had
from the beginning the idea of a
complete expulsion but she would have
sliced it into into very very small
pieces and then each bit managed very
carefully and she would have and she
would have taken clothes that she would
have paid close attention herself she
would have should have put appointed
somebody like Ben Wallace who she
trusted as as
um uh as mod but it would have been
under Daily Review in number 10. and
what would she and what do you say to
the people who say this is the West
interventions are necessary and in fact
by expanding East towards NATO's caused
this uh we are leading to World War III
and the potential for nuclear engagement
between the world's two superpowers why
don't we just let Russia have influence
over what it has it's it's right Ukraine
has Russia's fear of influence Putin's
talked about how it's it's just Russian
land that's temporarily called you
Ukraine you know what do you say to all
those people well I think the first the
first of them you know go back to my
original principles the right of
self-determination is individual
self-determination and state
self-determination you know
um and at the end of the day what does
Ukraine want to do you know uh the
nation of Ukraine uh that's the first
thing
um second thing is uh
I I don't pay a lot of attention to the
conspiracy theories and so on
um why
some of them might have some substance
of truth I don't know
um I'm not in a position to know to have
a detailed intelligence brief on what
what eu's activities in you know
pre-maden and so on uh were in in
Ukraine but laws are horrible roughage
things you know the things we did in the
second world war were you know there
were some nasty things we did you know
don't get talked about because we won
you know
quite uh you know and that and so I'm
afraid here once you're at War you've
got to recognize that this is I mean
there's there are still rules
um but yeah there's going to be lots of
stories flying around and you won't know
the truth for years and years and years
so we have to decide you know we are
supporting one side as what we should do
I don't suppose that side is perfect I
don't Supply I don't suppose
pre-invasion that that the Ukrainian
state was a perfect State any more than
well less than we are you know
um but it doesn't matter you know there
there is a big symbolic thing here and
it doesn't just affect Ukraine because
if we had stood back and let let Ukraine
fall
what would happen to Taiwan
what would happen elsewhere well the
next time and bear in mind this is what
number seven in Putin's uh excursions
you know you've got south of sat here
and uh abkhazia and all these other all
these other and all carefully calculated
I mean well you know we should be and
Syria you know I'm one of the few MPS
here who's been to Damascus since the
Syrian War I went and I saw Assad
um and spoke to him you know about what
was going on there and just as an aside
for you I think I've ever said this
publicly I said to him what's going on
because Russia's supposed to be pulling
out but when I crossed the border coming
across the burghard valley there were
clearly Russian what looked like space
dance
um at the border uh in the hotel I was
staying in in Damascus there were
plainly at least two sets of Russian air
crew
um
I don't speak enough words of Russian to
know what they were saying but I knew it
was rough
um and he said uh oh Putin has pulled
back because he's been accused of
undermining the peace process but I
spoke to him about it and Putin said to
me we will not let you lose
and astonishingly chilling things is way
back when this is 2016 I think it was
um there's a slightly chilling thing but
you know you see the calculation going
on and mostly As calculations have
worked in his favor you know South the
city why did they pick South to set here
south of said here
um uh part of Georgia has has um has
um you know got the highest number of uh
gallantry medal wins per capita in in
the old Soviet Union you know an
incredible high level of pro Russian
pro-soviet patriotism sort of thing that
they picked it for a reason you know
picking away and if he keeps winning
then he'll keep going and this has to
come a point this is the lesson of the
1930s you really didn't have nuclear
weapons in the 90s weapons but you you
can't allow nuclear weapons to then
suddenly just give the advice the other
side a lot of people said oh early on
there was lots of fear of this
um and bearman I grew up with nuclear
weapons but as I said part of my role in
in the reserve forces was that was
related to that
in the event of a nuclear exchange one
of the people who will be highly greatly
at risk will be Putin himself that's
what would happen now is this a man who
is a sort of you know
such a heroic self-image is willing to
give up his life this is a man who spent
two years in a bunker avoiding covid all
right the man who has meetings it
wouldn't have a meeting as close you
know his security meetings are you know
in a room as big as this but we fall
bigly you know
um the man is a man an aging man with
intimations of mortality you know so
he's not going to rush into a nuclear
change you don't be stupid about it you
don't take unnecessary risks but don't
don't let yourself be frightened by your
own weapons final question on this David
are we in Cold War Two yeah we are we've
been in it for a longer time than we
think I think all that's happened is we
haven't recognized it you know and we
have a calculator around it we have
what's happened is the war on terrorism
is elided through Syria in particular
into a sort of involuntary slippage into
into Cold War and this cold war actually
includes China too actually
um uh we have I mean we've allowed the
great benefit I talked about before the
1995 transformation
um
we have allowed the real benefits of
that
to blinders and handicappers in our
responses to things like China's
treatment of the uyghurs uh China's uh
basically kleptocratic approach
to uh to mod to State capitalism and we
should have been a bit more rigorous
about that but we aren't you know I'm
afraid that is the nature of Western
politics it is quite I mean democracies
are quite weak a lot of the time I mean
this struck me most starkly when uh
after
um after lipinenko uh killings a few
years later David Cameron was taking
um Putin to the Judo at the Olympics
what were we doing there what simple do
we think we're giving it you know for a
trivial
some diplomatic Advantage we were
telegraphing that we'd sort of forgiven
them for murdering people in our
territory you know we have to you know
there are lessons we have to relearn
uh in this world and Cold War Cold War
two or three whatever it is
um is not is not a bad description I'm
afraid but we've got to learn uh to
manage relations with not necessarily
actively hostile States but potentially
hostile States in such a way they know
there's a price for breaking our rules
David we're going to move on to a
subject very quickly there's even more
toxic in the Ukraine war which is
obviously brexit
um
what's going on with brexit at the
moment just sum it up for people who
aren't okay with Northern Ireland
discussions the protocol Etc well we we
got to we got to a a a a a a problematic
position after Theresa May many years
ago when when I was brexit actually
without talking to me agreed with the
European Union alignment full alignment
between the North and South of Ireland
right that created intrinsic problems
for us either a barrier within Britain
or we'd all have to follow uh you know
brexit becoming useless because it
wouldn't allow us to to deviate from
European standards and so on and from
that has been a Cascade of problems
which has been handled not terribly well
necessarily by successive governments
the
we got to a point really where we were
heading towards
a number of things one a barrier in the
North Sea which meant selling Goods in
from Great Britain into Northern Ireland
and vice versa uh was was just as bad as
selling them across a international
board
um and also not make it difficult for
the north to deal with the South as well
um what's happened in the last week uh
or so uh effectively last few months but
it's come the surfaced last week is that
Rishi has found a way Rishi sunak and I
think it's him personally
um has found a way of eradicating most
of the problems not all of them uh but
you know if you are selling Goods most
Goods to and from not all Goods most
Goods to and from Northern Ireland you
can do so without a barrier so we're
back to being a single nation right if
you're selling them to Northern Ireland
go south then it does go through a
barrier that's not a big deal
um we have got to the point where uh
we've got a block uh on
um
uh new laws being imposed in Northern
Ireland which um two blocks one they
will only relate to
uh its ability to trade they've got to
have a reference to that point so quite
a lot has been removed and secondly if
new ones come along we've got or at
least the Northern Ireland assembly 30
out of 90 of them for more than one
party are able to trigger a veto with
help with the support of the British
government
now when people say oh well how will
this work and so on I'll tell you how it
worked it'll act as a disincentive for
the for the Europeans to pick a fight
over it because we you know we have the
veto so there'll be a lot of talking
Will Go On which is fine I've got
nothing I've got no problem with that so
we've got at a long last and it's and
it's several years later than it should
have happened and it took so long
because we were too soft in the first
instance in our negotiating strategies
we didn't do a thatcher really
um uh We've long last got the point
where brexit is now looking like it's
working as it broadly should I mean I
would have preferred not to have to do
the deals in Northern Ireland but that
pass was sold by so it was about a long
time ago which would have led to my
resignation so so I think we've got a
good outcome and most important of all
not most important of all but an added
benefit
uh is also we're we're on a good
relationship with the Europeans you know
and they're our biggest neighbor and
that's what we should be aiming for that
you know you couldn't have at the
beginning because there was bound to be
tension at the beginning the resentment
all that that was inevitable but we're
now at a position where we're talking
them and the reasons for that
partly it's I think rishi's skill but
part of it is they suddenly realized
that if they kept pressing the way they
did they would destroy the Good Friday
agreement and the world would not
history would not forgive them right and
secondly uh post Ukraine
they realize that actually we're really
still very important to them you know
and even the people are most resempt for
brexit who I think the French probably
realize it most because you know the
major military power on the continent so
so I think that uh the outcome
is a good outcome in the final answer
it's not going to be perfect I guarantee
you the next week there will be loads of
little wrinkles oh look this and tell us
about this there's always that
International deals uh it's a pretty
good outcome which is why I I gave it a
stronger welcome and I normally give
most government actions this week and
you don't think the dup are going to try
and Scupper it well I think at the end
of the day the dup
um is look it's divided amongst itself I
think you know there's a spectrum of
users on DMV
um and I think there's there's a there's
a corollary which has got almost nothing
to do with brexit which is do they want
to go back into government we shouldn't
fight
they don't like being a government
wishing fine I don't think I'm this is
my surmise I don't know this I think
history will tell us that like they said
I think history would tell us that yeah
um and the the for whatever reason they
may not end up supporting this
um but you know they don't get their
powers unless they go back into
government they don't get their veto
power let's go back to the government so
I think there's a good incentive to
restart the Good Friday agreement the
the mechanisms of it
um they may abstain
they may even vote against the truth of
matter is this is going to get carried
and has a government by over 400 votes
because labor going to support it s p
are going to support it liberals will
end up supporting it
um and it will be seen broadly speaking
as a success and you've got people like
ranging from uh Steve Baker uh Rhys mogg
me you know people who you know people
are not later Rivals to brexit you know
we've been fighting these bats for a
long time saying this is the right
outcome and I think it is David it's
been an absolute pleasure thank you so
much for coming on the show it's been a
wonderful conversation we always finish
our interviews with the same question
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
science
technology the the future of the country
for the future of the world but the
future of this country in particular
because we are such a big science
is going to be dictated by everything
from
DNA
uh manipulation
um modern methods of of Health Care
um uh artificial intelligence you name
it and the level of public discussion of
technology today is
um
is you're two you're both you're too
young I've got all these old and
allergies it's sort of a level of
tomorrow's world it's all pop science
you know it's a science comic we don't
have enough people in government or in
public life generally who are scientists
who are who who are happily sit down so
let me give you an example
uh during coping we treated models the
the the product of models so there were
facts
remember all those Imperial models and
all that stuff you know and I wrote
along with um Matt Ridley an article
Telegraph way back beginning so look For
Heaven's Sake stop treating this as a
fact he's he's got every lasting
prediction wrong in all the pandemics so
far why should we think it's true now so
things like that the use of mathematics
the use of scientific techniques and so
on are very very poorly understood in
public life
um it's not so true in places like
Singapore and Japan but in this country
we've got to wake up the science
technology engineering mathematics are
the future and it's about time
governments start understanding it and
talking about it properly uh and the
public at large I want to my throwaway
last policy for you I want to do away
with University loans for stem subjects
I would like to put science technology
engineering and maths on a grant basis a
full Grant basis if anybody wants to do
it why do we do it one because the
reason I just told you two because I
think it'd be way
pulling really clever working class kids
into higher education because they look
at it as risky at the moment and give
them proper careers which is not
happening at the moment so that you know
it's a very Grand broad subject and I
could I could sit and talk for hours on
it but that's that for me is the big
hole in in modern politics
that's a great point and of course uh
you're you're canceling all the amazing
media studies graduates we've produced
over the last many decades in that
process it's been an absolute pleasure
we're going to ask you a couple of
questions that are supportive submitted
that only they will get to see on locals
but for now thank you so much for coming
on the show and thank you guys for
watching and listening pleasure we'll
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or all show all of
them go at 7 pm UK time and for those of
you who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
this is a very good question from clean
purple bunny what a name what do you
regret most about the British
government's response to covid and your
fight against it
[Music]